- I'm gonna be honest with you,
when season two came out, like there were
it was about to come out, it was like,
it's not gonna be anything
like season one, loved it!
Like it was better than season
one, that rarely happens.
(audience cheering)
Rarely happens.
- Thank you.
- I loved the new additions.
I loved y'all, the sisters coming.
I loved all of it.
I love the whole new story,
I loved the diverse cast,
I loved that.
I loved the tension was nice,
but I'm just curious if y'all
have like a favorite part
of like season two, like
either while you were shooting,
maybe something we
didn't know that happened
or just a part of the show.
- Ooh, I think my favorite scene to shoot
from season two was the
Holi scene in episode six.
- Yeah.
- Just because, you know, I think
you never really know how
people are gonna react
to certain scenes, right?
Like you hope for the best
and you can feel passionate.
But when we were feeling, when
we were filming that scene,
I think all of us, including the crew
felt this sense of like, oh my goodness,
we're kind of making history,
I don't think we've ever seen
something like this on screen before.
- Yeah.
- And it looked very different
to other scenes in the show.
- Yeah.
- And so it's really special to me
'cause it just feels so monumental.
- Yeah, something like new and fresh
as well.
- Yeah.
- That should have been happening.
- Yeah, I like that.
What's your favorite?
- I mean, I have to, I always
love dancing with Luke Newton.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
I love him.
- He's an amazing, but he
is like the best dancer
'cause he's musical theater trained
so that boy can sing, dance, act,
he can do it all.
- Oh, he's like one of those
old school movie stars.
- Oh 100%.
- I don't think I'm allowed
to say old school anymore,
but I just did it.
- Honestly, he just sent
me a picture of him,
I have to show it to you
for a fitting for season
three and oh my God.
(audience cheering)
It's really, I like felt
very weird, I was like Luke.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
- Yeah.
- So you're just like already filming
season three?
- We're already in fittings,
no, we're not filming yet,
but the fittings take a long time
'cause they make everything custom.
Literally every single
gown that we wear.
- Oh my God,
I fluctuate like so much,
like does that work out, like?
- I said, I was like, you know,
what if I like become a body builder?
They were like, that's
chill, we'll work around you.
- Or if you like.